this podcast has bad words
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists it's hard to give up
on the feeling that the life you really
want is out of reach
a new ig worthy home a promotion on the
horizon
all the right possessions
everyone wants to believe that they are
headed toward good better best today's
self-help industry insists on exhausting
positivity and on trying to
convince us convince us
that we can out eat out learn and
outperform our humanness
after trying to improve everything in
our lives we often discover we are as
fragile as the day we were born
today we're talking about toxic
positivity
with kate bowler kate thank you so much
for being here i'm so glad to be here
and just the supportive commentary
already
what a warm environment
you got a new book out it's called no
cure for being human and much of the
intro i just read there was an excerpt
from
the the back of the book and i want to
talk about the book we're going to dive
into it but i really want to talk about
we're so obsessed
with improving ourselves
and
i think it's making us miserable
can we talk about that oh yeah gospel of
hustle i mean it's
right it's a it was of course just a
terrible solution to
economic conditions right that the more
we were the less the government or
social services or
communities could provide one another
the more we became completely convinced
by
you know shocker other capitalist forces
that we were supposed to do it all on
our own and so now we're supposed to be
these
efficiency monsters these four hour work
weekers these zero inboxers like
adorable little versions of
post-fortis
factories and i honestly i'm like half
convinced in a regular day that i should
be that person like you take me away
from this podcast and i will be like
cranking through my inbox but the rest
of the time i'm like wait a minute
aren't i
working really hard on a treadmill that
is never going to end and is in fact
making me miserable
i think that's the part because life can
be perceived as a treadmill and that's
not a good or a bad thing but
if that treadmill is making us miserable
and part of that has to do with
comparison it feels like and and it has
something else to do with
well we're sold this sort of meme of the
pursuit of happiness yeah
and
it's that very pursuit that is making us
unhappy yeah and i think a lot of the
like ideologies that support it really
do come out of the late 19th century
rise of cities where i think you're
exactly right that the specter of
inequality seeing people who rise to the
top and others who fall to the bottom
made us i'm being generous here and
saying americans because i'm not
american but like they're not yeah yeah
thank you thank you so much but made us
reach more and more for explanations for
why some people like really is is there
such thing as luck or in some people
just harder working and more virtuous
and more capable of that kind of
independence we all want yeah and almost
ryan it seems like we
you and i often talk about sometimes it
is and it isn't like you can be capable
of achieving all of these things and
also luck played a factor in that as
well it's not either or well i guess he
or she is just lucky yeah i guess he or
she is unlucky
or i guess he is just a great achiever
and it's all effort it's all him him him
but then
is it really just him is it any any one
person
and um i know i think that you know
obviously there's platitudes galore here
the comparison is the thief of joy and
and all of these other things that that
um
i think there's profound truth in these
things but they've sort of been stripped
of their emotional residence resonance
because they've been used so frequently
so in in the new book no cure for being
uh human being for being human um
it seems to me that
we are almost avoiding our humanity yeah
yeah and i think sometimes with my s i
happen to be one of the people who are
typically described as unlucky and
um in my life i often find that like
it's much easier for people to reach for
um like a quick explanation for
why why
why me not them um
and i think some of these sort of like
facile reasons that we assign to our
lives sometimes they they're so
wonderful because they give us that
sense of like get up and go purpose in
the day energy drive horizon and the
rest of the time they can be an
incredible burden to people who don't
have the convenience of pretending that
we don't desperately need each other i
think instead of imagining
like the language strictly as that of
grief or
um
i guess like yeah i guess just like
grief for not having the lives we want i
guess i i just i'm kind of more of a fan
of like talking about finitude like how
about it's okay i mean i'm in the right
i'm at the right table for this in which
it's okay that enough like more than
enoughness is not the inherent rubric
for
success but that's what we're all
looking for it's more more more we never
stop to question what is
enough yeah yeah it's like you know
you're running on the treadmill and you
think i just need to run faster yeah but
sometimes you just need to step off
or just let it chew you out the back
right and then lie there for a minute
yeah
yeah and then
while recovering from your
like concussion you'll maybe have some
insight well ours is a listener driven
show so on this minimal episode today
we're going to talk about
toxic positivity now people often think
that the opposite of that as well i
guess i should just be negative there
what even is toxic positivity maybe we
can define that in a moment by the way
this episode is brought to you by
nobody
because advertisements suck
although if you want to support the
podcast you can become a patreon
supporter over at patreon.com
the minimalist you can join thousands of
other people we also put out an
additional episode every thursday over
there on patreon that's patreon.com the
minimalist that's the minimalist private
podcast ryan we have a question from
facebook rebecca has something for us
what are the signs that positivity has
become toxic for us as individuals and
what are the signs that our
well-intentioned positive vibes are
becoming toxic to others
yeah i like that question because it had
a lot of words in there that are
part of a vocabulary that we've absorbed
like vibes for example yeah good vibes
only yeah yeah yeah there's so many so
many vibes in the world and apparently
only half of them are the right kind
um yeah i mean and these are
like what we call sort of just this is
my american religious history
that i put on to begin sentences with it
was the late 19th century
but part of the concern there is that um
there's a there's a long tradition in
american religious history that imagines
that our minds are the most powerful
part about us that our minds are kind of
like these little incubators and that
are we what we have to do is sort of
harness thought in a particular way and
then direct it through the mechanism of
words um sort of to or at other people
which is partly how we get a lot of this
um
uh good vibes only there's a million
versions of it it's called positive
confession it's called um uh yeah
there's depending on what like religious
tradition you come from sure but um i
think that kind of aggressive positivity
in which you're only allowed then to
speak
optimistic things
um can be a huge burden if it prevents
you from being honest about the
about like the
usually the layered nature of the truth
of our lives like i am
i am joyful and also i'm
terrified about my health and um so i've
that i find encouragement um can can
really very quickly uh
take a detour into preventing people who
are suffering from saying anything that
makes us feel sad under the guise of
positivity so i would say it's a burden
when it prevents us from being honest
and it prevents any kind of sentence
that can't have an and in it right it
almost feels as though there's this
binary you either have to be
positive which we then say is good yeah
and and then it's value judgment on
everything and then if we're not
positive then it is bad right and then
there's like this weird sort of
moralizing aspect of that as well
if you are not positive in a way it's
it's immoral but at the same time the
antidote to that isn't well then walking
around and complaining that's not what
we're talking about either just a wide
end i just kind of think of it like a
like in a camera like a widened aperture
for the light and the dark you get all
the granular details then and so all i
want is and you know i'm a jesusy person
so i just have a lot of like god just
let me see the world as it is like let
me just and let that include both the
beautiful truths and the ones that are
that i
would really rather not see yeah
yeah i'm thinking about about
whenever we
we hear about these negative emotions or
we build a camaraderie by complaining
with friends or family or whatever
and that's not the
antidote to this this toxic positivity
so what really is
the
why
because i'm not yeah i'm a positive
person overall and people tend to see
the i'm overwhelmingly positive but
it's not an affectation either yeah i
think maybe it's the affect that is the
toxic part of this because the opposite
is also toxic and i would even say more
toxic the the constant complaining the
shaming the blaming
those things are all toxic as well yeah
i guess the problem too with just the
language of positivity is we're
describing so many things at the same
time right we're describing um affect
and we're describing personality
sometimes um one of the
consequences of being middle class i
just read this book on sort of the
history of class and one of them is um
is uh is ingrained optimism and i was
like oh i thought i had a personality
but it turns out i'm just middle class
so sometimes it's a function of class
and circumstance um sometimes too though
it's this it's part of this really deep
religious and psychological strain in
american culture that pretends that our
minds are always the kind of drivers of
our entire existence when in fact thank
you to the rise of trauma studies
language of embodiment that we're always
kind of doing multiple things at the
same time we're both our genetics we're
our experience where our and emotions
aren't simply something we just like
direct with our insert scary face smile
right now but that we're we're a flood
of a whole constellation of different
positive or negative forces and living
and sorting through it is part of the
like wisdom of figuring out how to how
just how to be honest while we are
people again today um
so
so you said that being middle class you
have an ingrained positivity positivity
yeah interesting it's what i first
thought of was like well
maybe that's because uh you know they're
the middle class like has things that
they are striving for
reaching for hoping for
where like someone who's rich kind of
like has it all yeah and it's horizon
work that's what i think of it like when
um that one of the functions of class
right it's resources and so when people
have limited resources they just have to
constantly work with a horizon that
feels really short and then therefore it
creates chaos because they can't create
predictability and and that's why people
become what they call like choice poor
it's like every choice costs too much
yes and then they you know and then we
all get it's like if you've they did
this with game simulation where they're
like they gave a certain set of kids a
lot of choices as turns and then some
kids fewer choices and at first the kids
with fewer
turns played really carefully but at
some point they just got tired and then
they start spending their choices
you know the way we do when we get tired
and so joy when we're choice poor it can
be everything can feel intense and
fraught if you have an extended horizon
like with the middle class
you do get that longer runway feeling
you get that that's how you get your
like
striver men like mentality and theology
you get your like
hustle hustle hustle and the upper class
is typically defined by a limitlessness
like in everything they have the
embodiment of everything as possible
where the middle class just sort of
screams it at each other
and yet we've seen through history
where that any of those things are
possible no matter where you are on the
socioeconomic spectrum we've all we all
see examples of extremely poor people
who have a sort of abundance mindset
right and then we have
you know rich people billionaires when
the stock market goes down they're
hurling themselves out of windows
because of the scarcity mindset oh i
can't believe i'm only i'm only a
hundred millionaire now i'm no longer a
billionaire how can i possibly live in a
world like this
right
and so we've seen that you know it's
possible maybe there's a certain
mysticism that's required or or
transcending
the the circumstances although i want to
talk to you about this because the last
three years i've had some pretty
significant health complications in my
own life and you're not unfamiliar with
that um and it's nothing compared to you
but it's not a comparison thing here but
what i found in those moments where it
is most challenging for me i find that
i'm less generous
and i don't know what it is about that
there's something about
um
the fear yeah that doesn't allow us to
be uh yeah our ourselves yeah it's a
very clenched kind of place fear
yeah and i i think that i mean that
makes sense that we just we start
counting differently the math of our
life becomes very
small and finite it is it is hard to
i guess i've kind of had a
i guess i've kind of had both
experiences weirdly depending on what
sort of terrible things i've been going
through but like there have been moments
in my life where
because i was undone like i'm just
thinking of the
moment where i was
you know there's no cancer in my family
all of a sudden i'm told i have stage
four cancer and it felt like my brain
like i felt like i was floating in space
like it just it couldn't possibly be
true
i had to walk over to the hospital
and i like nothing was ever going to be
okay again i was positive about that
and i could just feel because um
adorably i work at a place where my my
place of employment i work at a divinity
school so it's mostly teaching like
non-profit workers or pastors of that
type and is like just about five minute
walk from the hospital
and they just
so i'm like like change out of my pretty
fun lecture dress and then into like
this sad hospital gown and i was like
well like this like this is my new life
and then they came over in all their
little suits and they popped all their
little clerical collars out of their gym
bags and there's just like
22 they're like how many pastors do you
have because you're allowed to get in if
you're a pastor so they're like after
hours and they just came in and like
just like a hand on my shoulder or like
on my head and just like
saying to me and like like they just
they just have all the stuff they've got
the like
sweet little like anointing oil just
like they just bubble wrapped me with so
much love that even though i didn't know
who i was and i felt like honestly like
just like my life is over in the way
that i know it and just that was i've
never felt like i had that much
abundance and that was made by entirely
by other people's love wow so cyrena and
then i feel like when we have less we
when we sort of surrender the illusion
of it every now and then people are just
they just life raft you you know wow
yeah um mallory do we have any tissues
by the way
um i'm gonna use this i'm just gonna
hope this this silk is absorbing you
grab a paper towel in there
so
wow um
or i can be reggie and sad and petty i
mean it's really a lot of choices i got
a i got a both hand situation
let's uh let's talk to
barley in boise idaho one of the
issues that i've seen come up
about
minimalism
is the
that many people see it as elitism so
i read a comment on a blog the other day
that said
quote i think that one reason i've never
embraced minimalism is that there seems
to be an inherent disconnect with true
suffering that makes it difficult to
have a healthy relationship with those
that don't have the same privileges as
me
and i've also heard that
it is another form of conspicuous
consumption
a way of saying to the world look at me
look at all of the things i have refused
to buy
and i don't necessarily agree with those
viewpoints but i was just wondering
interested in what you would have to say
on those
things and if you think
minimalism is a type of
elitist
barley i guess it means
i guess it depends on what you mean by
minimalism
if you just mean like you the
if you mean asceticism that
is sort of a material asceticism
it that doesn't seem particularly elite
to me
um
but if it if it's
someone selling minimalism like you go
to the gap and they're selling shirts
that say minimalism on it
then yeah that doesn't make a whole lot
of sense that's not what i think of when
i think of minimalism let's just take
the word minimalism out of this because
that seems to be confusing you right now
i totally get it because there's baggage
with any of these terms we use so let's
pick a different ism let's just call it
intentionalism right
whatever you want to call it if you're
living
intentionally what does that mean it's
i'm using whatever resources i have in a
deliberate way
now
when ryan and i grew up really poor food
stamps government assistance
we certainly could have benefited from
being more intentional with the few
resources we had yeah and throughout our
20s as we climbed the corporate ladder
and we
accumulated a ton of debt and got all
the trinkets of success we also would
have benefited from minimalism then
being more intentional with our
resources because we made really good
money but we spent even better money and
so we had huge amounts of debt we
weren't being intentional either time
when we were broke and poor and
impoverished
and when we were
supposedly successful at least
ostensibly successful right
and and so
if we're talking about the intentional
use of whatever is in front of you your
time your money your energy your
attention
well then who wouldn't benefit from that
and so maybe minimalism isn't for
everyone but it's for anyone who is
questioning the status quo or at least
being intentional
is for anyone who is questioning the
status quo
i'm as as a bit of an outsider from
minimalism kate i'm wondering
what what are your thoughts on this when
you hear someone talking about
minimalism or simple living i can see
how it would conjure some images of this
i think the only thing that
to me would signal
like not giving up the premise right if
the premise
if the premise of any of it is control
then then then you could do that with
with fewer belongings or with more
belongings i remember finding out that
the
average reader of real simple magazine
had like a
just a wild family household income
it was something like 180 000 or
something for a household and i was like
oh that's very simple that's extremely
simple living
real simple but um
i think what the i think the the the the
aesthetic that what i was what i was
reading in some things was just that
that beautiful spartan quality was just
another way of saying look at all the
time i have to curate everything in such
a way that it makes my life feel like
it's full of beautiful choices
and that can be quite elitist and quite
i think if the illusion is
that we can determine every aspect of
our lives with our magical choices then
yes i believe that is utterly [ __ ]
yeah yeah but i think if we
recognize that most many some
of the things that are going to turn
determine our lives are the things we
don't get to choose and then we live
with we just try to live with truth and
beauty and intentionality with the rest
then i say
make me a minimalist yeah so
tell me what what is your definition of
an elitist either of you
what is an elitist someone who's rich
and
[Music]
and what what make what makes a rich
person an elitist i don't know what
makes a rich person at least i can tell
you what elite means to me
elite means performing above and beyond
something now we use elitist
pejoratively yeah um and so i don't
really know exactly what it means and so
i'm not defending any point i just don't
i don't know
i think that word is thrown out there in
a way to almost shut down conversations
right there are a lot of words like that
they're shaming words in a way where
where we we throw out these words not to
have a discussion around the thing but
to almost shut down a discussion around
a thing
and i'm not saying that barley is doing
that here but whoever was
was you know commenting on whatever post
she was reading on on the internet
it's almost as a a way to be completely
dismissive well because you can take
anything and make it into the pageant of
that thing i'm just thinking of the
you know when the when the when the pope
who has
you know and and
some of the most religious money in in
in the universe will wear like slippers
right as a gesture of humility and like
that there's that in the midst of um
that any any theology
ideology set of choices can always be
like a quarter turn away from the from
the parity of it in which we can you
know perform all of our values without
necessarily having to like live with the
contradiction of them so i hear i hear
it when we have to strip down yes you're
imagining choice you're imagining the
the illusion that um life is something
to be controlled and that's only
something is what i heard in that
question that the people with lots of
choices can do yeah
but also we none of us get out of the
problem of having to make these really
like there's a lovely and boring word
for it it's prudential wisdom prudence
is this wonderful word that just means
the wisdom to to see those fine
distinctions and know i think that's
what you guys are talking about yeah so
an elitist i guess could be a minimalist
but i'm sure yeah but i don't know if
it's the other way because like i look
at
well you're a gcc person i would call
jesus a minimalist was he an elitist you
know yeah it depends on what you mean by
elitist in that sense right and that's
why i ask the question is because like
what does it mean by elite to me it's
when someone says
minimalism is for elitists only or
whatever
i mean they're just shutting down the
conversation they are they're looking at
it and saying
i couldn't live that way
because of my own desires and my own
actions
and so i'm going to put a label on it
that is going to give me permission
to avoid this you know minimalism i love
what you talked about you know
take minimalism out of it i mean look at
intentionalism or deliberatism or
curationism or whatever it is right i
mean when you look at it that way it's
hard to it's hard to sit here and say
like well only
minimalism is only good for rich people
i mean i've seen countless articles
where it's like minimalism doesn't work
for the poor it's like why would you why
would you exclude someone like that yeah
like well it's just it's fascinating to
me because
um
i'd have to pretend that we don't get
all these letters and emails and phone
calls from people from everywhere from
kenya to kalamazoo
who are talking about wherever they are
on the socio-economic spectrum what
they've realized is we've been
acculturated to have certain desires
that aren't our desires it's called
memetic desire right and and so there's
all of these sort of cultural desires
that are propagated by our religion by
culture by society by our peer groups by
our co-workers by wherever we are in our
city in in
in our careers and
these things are quite often
making us miserables she mentions
suffering
and
everyone is suffering the people i see
suffering the most and it's not that
it's not that one is better than the
other quite often the people i see
suffering the
most are the ones who i would look at
and say you have no reason to be
miserable yeah
but
that doesn't make the suffering any less
real there's kind of a nice little um
because i
like the problem of desire i know it's
like every every
philosophical
you know
school has this
problem of like the problem of desire
and like is it okay that we want things
and
do we increase our own suffering by
wanting too much or chasing the like
creating malformed desires and then
drowning in them you know and we see
that
all the time with lovely people who just
keep trying and trying and trying and
buying and buying or
they just never get there and wherever
there is
it's not a place they live and uh
and there's a lovely like little
i just remember having this problem
after coming out of the hospital
when i was trying to figure out like
okay well
i don't know how long i'm going to live
but i know i have to like figure out
some kind of way of doing this and
obviously my way of doing this before
was my super super hustle train and i
was great at it
and now i that can't be the driver and i
found why can't it be the driver
because i could just i mean i i could i
would just make
i would let that feeling
of productivity consume everything else
i think that's a big driver the desire
to be productive
that's also a memetic desire right other
people we see them
hands moving and
gtd whatever it is getting things done
and hustle hustle hustle right i made
that whole system one time and had lots
of folders yes like every day was a
folder
and if your partner talks to you like
you have to put it on a note then put
that note in the day folder and i was
like i don't feel like we have that kind
of relationship
it's
the spreadsheets of goals all of these
things well there's nothing inherently
wrong with them
what i see is
we're creating a culture that is
obsessed with doing things that make us
miserable and that's why i asked well
why is that not sustainable for you
because the question you asked like okay
i got out of the hospital i said okay
now what no one yeah now what now what i
can't really can we all ask that yeah i
really hope i mean
my
drama tends to give me more like uh you
know i just get like stark choices
sometimes but i really do think we all
get this these really we all get the
problem of
now what like we've got
number days
hours
resources
people to love everything about us is
narrows to a dot on the horizon and
because of that like what now and i
i had really let like that kind of like
being in fifth gear feeling to it helped
me get out a lot of
difficult circumstances i was like well
i was one of the only women who could
get like a job in my field i
i mean i was able to be hyper productive
at a time in which no human person
should be able to
and uh and all of that gave me a certain
amount of sense of purpose and joy
and then all the rest of it made me feel
exhausted and scared yeah and like it
was it was never gonna be enough and i
didn't even know how to to just get off
the get get out of the paradigm i think
i think the toxic part of the what we're
talking about here with the toxic
positivity
is the exhausted and scared
and fearful and grieving that turns into
self-pity which i want to talk to you
about on the maximal here in a second
but um actually before we move on to the
lightning round
barley i want to send you some tickets
we're going to be uh in salt lake city
you're in boise you got to make the
drive down what is that 84 to 15
something like that
i don't know i'm not an atlas
[Laughter]
don't worry if he has the entire united
states tattooed on his back really
why have we not gotten into this before
josh she said you would never tell
it's a [ __ ] stamp really is what it is
[Laughter]
watch me
barley we're coming to 20 cities it's
the love people use things tour we just
had a new book come out it's called love
people use things because the opposite
never works
and uh one of the cities we're coming to
is right down the street from you there
in salt lake city we'll be there oh this
month the tour starts today when this
episode comes out which is next tuesday
and we're going all over the place uh us
canada as well
we'll be on the coast so new york and
boston and dc and we'll be in florida
and nashville and atlanta and three
cities in texas and
la and san francisco and denver a bunch
of other places the minimalists.com tour
if you're interested but barley we're
going to send you a couple tickets for
the salt lake event ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to 937-202-4654
that's the first time i've been able to
say that number without looking at it
you looked really focused
the irony of this is those texts they go
to both of our phones literally so
people can text us and but like we just
have this app it's a shared app that we
we use together anyway kate during the
lightning round so ryan and i and our
guests we do our best to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response
that's a minimal max it has to be
something really pithy like buy low sell
high yeah yeah yeah write that down sean
throw that take dictation
uh we put that we do put them in the
show notes so people can copy and share
the pithy answers on social media you
can monitor on a bit we'll tweeze
something out and make it look beautiful
carrie has a question for us where did
the notion come from that being positive
is the cure for everything the path for
everyone the solution to whatever life
throws at you
what's wrong with embracing sadness
contemplation grief anxiety
um well here's my pithy answer for you
maybe we can unpack it a little bit so
self-pity
is the bedrock of toxic certainty
let's sit on that for a second
so so i think quite often yeah there's
nothing wrong with grieving there's
nothing wrong with these things we've
got to stop moralizing and if we want to
better understand how we feel right
because then we just repress it oh i'm
anxious anxious i shouldn't be anxious
and therefore let's just hide that let's
pretend that always works you know i can
cover it up if you push it deep down
it'll never bubble up right that's what
the down part is for
the whole directional problem i'll hide
it by being more positive yeah oh man
yeah and yet i think we can get
certainty as well from this sort of
self-pity where it's like oh what was me
you know it's
and then now now that is my place of
certainty which is a
basic human need we all have a need for
some amount of certainty but one of the
ways we get emotional certainty
is
being
trapping ourselves in that cycle in a
way did you ever experience that when
you when you especially with your
diagnosis well i felt because i guess my
plan for before was the kind of
everything as possible plan and then
when everything was not possible i was
like well i can't do the opposite which
would be fatalism and despair and
nothing is possible
so i tried i guess i'm i'm more and more
obsessed with the idea of limited
agency
little place of action little place of
intention but yeah and i and just always
being able to ask well then if it's not
everything it's not nothing then what is
possible today and that little bit of
runway is a place where i can find
um freedom but not the kind of illusion
of of of self-mastery yeah
there's something beautiful we can
tweeze out there sean yeah it sounds uh
it's like the
the balance between
anything is possible and nothing is
possible and that's
i think that's what minimalism helps
well helps me do that it just kind of
finds that middle ground um yeah that's
that's awesome
um uh my fifth answer is this our
emotions are mountains the peaks create
the valleys
we have to experience the negative with
the positive but if we stay in the
valley it's going to be a problem if we
try to stay on the peak it's going to be
a problem yeah what i love about this
answer is it also exposes something as
well that our need for the peaks
creates deeper valleys in our lives so
the chasing of the happiness that we
talked about earlier
if we're constantly you know the
adrenaline junkie or whatever it creates
these these deeper valleys for us
and uh and although you know what's
beautiful about that is sometimes those
valleys are really beautiful too yeah
right
i've heard who i have a friend that she
says um
like that that those valleys they can
like excavate out deeper joy
and so like it digs out something inside
of you so it's not just that you're in
the valley but like
it like it helps you go richer and
deeper than you could have otherwise and
i think that's right yeah i don't know
people who haven't experienced a lot of
pain who don't have an incredible
capacity for joy yeah that's yeah i
agree with that you know it's
interesting what i've been trying to do
i just kind of realized this over the
last year like whenever i experience
negative emotions whether it's sadness
or anger whatever it is
instead of like trying to
shove it down or
uh
worse like you know um
exacerbate it right like
i can take that emotion and i can be
like oh wow like how lucky am i it's
really even experience this this this
negative emotion that doesn't mean that
i am enjoying the negative emotion
but i can at least like look at it like
oh this is part of humanity yeah you
notice your aliveness yeah exactly and
there's there's actually there is um
i think there can be some beauty in
those in those negative emotions i'm not
saying yeah every single time but i have
been able to find beauty like just the
sadness that i feel sometimes it's like
uh it's like a wow like how lucky am i
to like care this much about something
you know yeah yeah russian literature
wouldn't exist if they weren't like you
know this really sad emotion
doesn't need a lot of novels yeah not a
lot of positivity and dostoyevsky
yeah well we got so much more to talk
about but ryan you got something for us
first oh yeah here are some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
check them out hi josh and ryan um i
just wanted to share an experience i had
with your listeners um because i often
think about
what to do and situations with gift
giving and gift receiving
and
when my birthday rolled around this year
i really wanted to have a talk with
some of my friends about how i want to
celebrate and
how i don't really want physical gifts
because a lot of the times i don't use
the things that they give me
and
when we started talking about it they
actually
um to my surprise agreed and
they were actually talking about how
they really don't even like to just
aimlessly walk around the mall and just
trying to kind of find something that
they think i might like and
um
we all agreed that it was kind of a
pointless and
aimless um unintentional way to shop for
somebody and
i was really surprised at what they had
to say about it and that they actually
agreed not to do gifts this year um so i
just wanted to encourage everybody to
have those discussions even though
they're hard because you never know what
they might say and they might actually
be relieved to hear that um you don't
want a gift and
they can save money that way and just
enjoy their time with you
yeah i just wanted to let everybody know
that
some people will actually agree with you
even if they're not minimalists
hi my name is clara bail i'm from
amherst massachusetts
so i really enjoy your podcast um i am
in the military i'm a member of the
coast guard and i'm really liking seeing
the connection between middle and muslim
and being in the military you know we
have the same uniform every day really
just a basic amount of stuff and just
having that freedom of
everything you need just keeping in what
we call our sea bag which is that green
military-like backpack thank you and i
really enjoy your podcast all right job
big thanks to kate bowler her new book
is called no cure for being human
you can check it out well wherever you
check out books we'll put a link to it
in the show notes as well she also has a
podcast called everything happens
and we'll put a link to that as well
also
katebowler.com i believe is the website
you know there we go yeah i visited
daily
it's a practice it's a meditative
practice we got a bunch more surprise
questions for kate this thursday over on
patreon that's the maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast but first
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist k we're getting
ready to go out on tour
and so we're going to be all over the
place 20 different cities
jordan just made this beautiful new
trailer tour trailer it's hilarious uh
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
check out this tour trailer it's um well
it's the process of ryan and i writing
this book you get to see the entire
three-year process in about a minute
and it's exactly verbatim how it went
right and then uh yeah you can check it
out uh it's just the minimalists.com
tour for any of those cities we're going
to 20 different cities for our added
value this week anybody here familiar
with william tyler
he has a
phenomenal album which is called modern
country which is weird because it's not
country music
but modern country
and the song is called highway anxiety
and
tim
who was hanging these paintings from
from uh wove arts he was like hey i'm
really into the minimalist composers and
i think this would be right up your
alley but it's sort of
neo-minimalism in terms of composition
and it's all instrumental so let's end
this episode today with some highway
anxiety by the way we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week like how do
i balance positivity and disappointment
why does kate avoid creating a bucket
list
how do we deal with the frustration that
arises when people insist that our
trauma is a gift
what do you do about the overwhelming
expectation that surviving something
traumatic like cancer should lead you to
a joyous epiphany and a constant
positive outlook on life plus a million
more questions for kate and the
minimalists and if you want to hear all
that join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalists come to one of our live
podcast shows visit
the minimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com
if you leave here today with just
one message
let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'd be fine
without it